janeshia was an amazing city of the Maya
what we see now it's the civic and
religious part of it so we can tell
these buildings were sacred El Castillo
or temple of Kukulkan it's an amazing
building based on astronomical in
mathematical science I've been leading a
team of archeologists and researchers to
explore the underground water system
below chichen itza for several years the
great Maya aquifer project is a very
ambitious exploration with the aims of
knowing this huge amount of water that
lays under the ground the aquifer was
sacred because it contained water water
became a religious concept for them as
well
cenotes are the collapse of caverns
holes in the ground and we see and we
can access the aquifer cenotes were
super important for the Maya because
they are part of the underworld we have
heard for a long time the oral tradition
of the elder that the El Castillo was
built over a cavern or cenote but we
also have scientific proof of that what
we know north south east and west for
the ancient Maya were four directions of
the universe they had a fifth direction
that we don't use on our cardinal points
which is the center the axis mundi they
believed everything were created from
that Center they center themselves in
the cosmos we have been working very
hard on trying to find an entrance to
this fifth direction of the Maya
universe trying to find an underground
pathway that we can dive to this cenote
what I want to achieve it's a much
better knowledge not only finding
amazing sites which is of course a very
nice part of our project but to
understand better the life of the
yeah through the great Maya aquifer
through the caves through everything
they do under the ground
you